the fastest run to the cleric beast is
via this shortcut which you can learn
about in the previous episode of the
drain guide now there is a bit to learn
about fighting the cleric beast and
there are very good ways to do it and
very bad ways if you're doing it the
very bad way
you're probably swearing at the camera a
lot and if you're doing it the good way
you're probably intimately familiar with
his thighs but the fight can be over in
two minutes if you do it my way in
particular there are three very
effective ways to damage him that make
this fight a breeze step one the
majority of your damage to the cleric
beast should be from charge attacks
these do way more damage and they
[ __ ] his limbs faster
whenever you charge your attack with are
to aim for his legs or his arms to fully
charged attacks on any Lyn should be
enough to [ __ ] it and when he keels
over like this you have another chance
to fully charge an attack again or heal
you can tell which limb you damaged
because it will be all bloodied and
messed up so unlock your camera and
spend most of your time as close as you
can possibly get to his legs or his back
his sideswipe attack does barely any
damage and if you keep an eye on what
his arms are doing you should be able to
dodge effectively through all of his
attacks if you're directly behind him he
can't damage you at all if the cleric
beast is ever backed against the wall
it's very difficult to position yourself
correctly so if this happens we move on
to step two lock onto the cleric beast
and dash backwards you want to position
him in the middle of the bridge if you
can because then we always have room to
get around him and while you're
repositioning him chances are you'll
have the chance to shoot him lock onto
his upper body and start aiming for his
head after a few shots on his head he
will keel over and give you the
opportunity to initiate a critical
attack with our one after you've done
your critical on his head you won't be
able to do it again until he heals it
this is his healing animation keep an
eye out for it he can heal all of his
limbs as well so you should pay
attention to this red glow because the
red glow is around the body part he
heals and once he's healed it it means
you can stagger him again if this fight
is done correctly the cleric beast
should spend half his time being
staggered or healing himself making it
very easy for you to keep up your
assault
you'll have plenty of times to he
granted you stay behind him and keep an
eye on his arms at this point the cleric
beast should be below 33% health and
around this point he gets stupidly
aggressive like he attacks non-stop even
if you're nowhere near him use this to
your advantage and move on to step 3
so lock on and back away from the cleric
beast or just sprint away from him and
throughout central yharnam in the first
episode of the guide there was about 10
Molotov cocktails and oil urns that you
should have found in the world
so start lobbing these at the cleric
beast because fire does increase damage
to beasts be careful of his long-range
attacks but that's it this fight should
definitely be over at this point and you
should have killed him in less than 2
minutes so if this helped you please
leave a like and subscribe if you want
to join me for your adventures through
blood-borne the only question I have
with this cleric beast fight is what
exactly does damaging his limbs do I
know it stuns him when you bleed out one
of his limbs and he has to spend time
healing them but I feel like there could
be some subtle effect I haven't noticed
perhaps he does less damage with a
damaged arm or perhaps he can't jump
with a damaged leg or maybe you do more
damage to a damaged limb if you research
this enough and find an answer then just
let everyone know you should head over
to the vexed relief page which have got
listed in the description this is the
page for the cleric beast and you can
edit it yourself and just add your own
tips to the list it's really cool we can
all contribute what we know to the
community thanks for watching guys if
you want more guides that feel free to
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next one the way